quel smartphone venir acheter au mois de
février 2024 c'est vraiment le mois
qu'on attendait parce que je vous l'ai
dit au mois de janvier il y avait plein
de nouveautés qui allaient arriver avec
d'un côté les Galaxy S24 qui sont juste
là d'un autre côté le S24 ultra il y a
les Xiaomi les redmi note 13 pro plus et
compagnie on a également le rock phone
d'Asus bref il y a énormément de
produits qui sont arrivés ce qui rabat
un peu les cartes et en plus de ça il y
a des prix qui changent donc on va
regarder quel smartphone acheter
différents prix et d'ailleurs je vais
lancer un live tous les mois où je vais
venir vous aider à choisir vos
smartphones ça sera réservé aux membres
de la chaîne mais la toute première
vidéo je vais la faire pour tout le
monde peut-être que je switcherai un
moment le chat si vraiment j'arrive plus
à lire c'est compliqué de venir répondre
aux questions pour venir vous aider à
choisir vos smartphones je donne la date
je note dans mon agenda c'est le jeudi 8
février et on se retrouvera à 20h comme
ça vous le voyez je me marque hop là
live Youtube je me le mets le 8 février
notez-le en même temps dans votre agenda
ça sera à 20h on se retrouvera on
passera peut-être 1h 1h30 j'en sais
fichtrement rien ça va dépendre de vous
de vos questions je vais vous aider à
venir trouver le ou les smartphones qui
sont faits pour vous je vous le dis ça
sera réservé aux membres donc pensez à
devenir membre bien évidemment mais la
toute première vidéo je l'ouvrirai à
tout le monde pour vous puissiez voir et
après voir si ça vous intéresse pour
devenir membre bien évidemment vous avez
le bouton rejoindre qui est juste en bas
sinon vous le notez dans votre agenda on
se retrouve à cette date pour venir vous
aider à trouver votre
smartphone allez moins de 200 balles on
va commencer c'est un produit que je
voulais vous montrer marque Espagno qui
s'appelle SPC le modèle c'est le
Discovery pro 169,90 € bon voilà on a
pour son argent on a pour un peu plus de
150 balles on va pas trop en demander
mais si on veut un smartphone qui vient
d'Espagne c'est européen voilà comme ça
au moins vous savez à quoi vous en tenir
sur ce modèle alors après on va
commencer à arriver dans d'autres
modèles qui m'intéressent on va
commencer à se parler de Xiaomi avec le
redmi note 13 nouveauté de cette année
on est à un peu moins en dessous de 200
balles 199,90 € et vous voyez que sur la
config avec 6 Go de RAM et 128 Go de
stockage et bien vous l'avez ici à un
peu moins de 200 balles donc on est sur
un smartphone 4G c'est pas une foudre de
guerre mais ce qui est intéressant ici
si vous voulez c'est que vous avez un
truc qui est très honnête c'est pas un
truc de fou en photo mais pour avoir un
smartphone du qutidien un tarif maîtrisé
ça c'est bien je vous en parle un peu
plus loin dans la vidéo mais les Samsung
Galaxy S24 sont arrivés d'ailleurs que
vous souhaitez acheter un Samsung Galaxy
S24 ou alors un autre smartphone et bien
vous pouvez venir les acheter
directement chez mon partenaire BCK
Telecom et l'excellente nouvelle c'est
que BCK Telecom est partenaire à l'année
de la chaîne comme ça on aura l'occasion
de reparler d'avoir d'excellents bon
plans avec BCK tellecom et ce qui est
génial c'est que si vous souhaitez
acheter un Galaxy S24 ou alors un Galaxy
S24 plus ou alors pourquoi pas un
Samsung Galaxy S24 ultra et bien vous
pouvez venir les acheter directement en
boutique chez book Telecom ou alors
directement sur leur site web bien
évidemment je vous mets juste un lien en
bas dans la description il y a très
belles offres avec tous les forfait que
propose B teléecom vous allez forcément
trouver un forfait qui vous convient que
ce soit en 4G que ce soit en 5g et tout
ça des tarifs extrêmement alléchant en
plus de ça wi telecope propose une
excellente couverture réseau que ce soit
en 4G et bien évidemment en 5G je vous
invite donc à venir cliquer sur le lien
qui est présent juste en bas dans la
description ce qui nous emmène à la
catégorie des 200 à 500 € alors là on va
arriver tout de suite sur un smartphone
un poil plus cher on reste chez Xiaomi
je voulais vous montrer le redmi note 13
5G cette fois-ci bien forcément on est
au-dessus des 200 on est un peu moins en
dessous des 300
299,90 € une seule version 8 256
plusieurs couleurs par contre qui nous
intéresse vraiment ici c'est soit
l'univers 4G on est à moins de 200
balles soit l'univers 5G on est à un peu
plus 200 balles peu plus 300 balles tant
qu'on est chez Xiaomi sur les redmi on
va y rester parce qu'il y a d'autres
modèles qui sont arrivés qui sont aussi
intéressants on va vooir le redmi note
13 pro la boîte est juste là
regardez-moi ça il est mignon il est
joli il est juste là et bien celui-là
forcément et bien vous en aurez un petit
peu plus on va se retrouver avec une
caméra principale de 200 mgapixel avec
stabilisateur alors attention c'est pas
parce que c'est du 200 mégapixel que
c'est le meilleur 200 mgapixel ça permet
de capter un peu plus de lumière bon ok
la recharge rapide ils aiment bien
montrer un peu les muscles ici tout ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce grand écran
AMOLED 120 Hz Full HD plus donc pour du
contenu multimédia c'est cool la grosse
batterie de 5000 ce qu'on attend
également le processeur il sera correct
attention on n'est pas sur un truc de
fou non plus mais ça fonctionnera et
puis après bon vous avez plein de trucs
l'ultra grand tle de 8 mégapixel on va
pas trop lui en demander la macro de 2
mégapixel on va rien lui demander du
tout on va essayer de sauver un peu les
meubles avec le 200 mgapixel bon une
fois de plus on est sur un tarif
maîtrisé c'est pas là qu' on va voir le
truc le plus impressionnant mais
globalement ça fera le taf et tout ça au
tarif de
349,90 € sur la version 8 256 et sur la
version 12 512 on est à
399, 90 alors après on va monter tout de
suite plus haut c'est pour faire le tour
un peu de de cette nouvelle gamme avec
le redmi note 13 pro plus non rallonge
là on va tout de suite beaucoup plus on
va être face à un Galaxy A54 de Samsung
tandis que le redmi note 13 pro on
serait plus face à un à 34 pour essayer
de de les situer alors la version Pro
plus 469,90 € en 8 256 forcément son V12
ça monte en tarif vous allez voir parce
que Samsung a baissé un peu les tarifs
ça c'est le truc qui qui m'intéresse
aussi si je regarde chez Samsung il y a
plein de nouveaux produits qui sont sur
sortie il y a déjà le A15 5G qui a 249
balles vous le voyez il vous marque
écran Super AMOLED 6,5 pouces Full HD
plus triple capteur photo capteur
principal de 50 mégapixel ça franchement
c'est intéressant à 249 balles on a un
truc qui est très honnête on va monter
un peu plus à 319 on garde toujours du
Super AMOLED c'est la même techno
toujours le même écran 120 Hz cette
fois-ci toujours le capteur de 50
mgapixel 319 €. ça déjà c'est vraiment
vraiment intéressant c'est des grosses
nouveautés et ça vaut le coup après je
regarde un truc c'est class à 15 je
vousou l'ai montrer en version 5G mais
si vous le voulez en version 4G et bien
vous l'avez à 219 € 6,5 pouces Full HD
plus Super AMOLED capteur principale de
50 m pixel c'est vrai que sur un
smartphone 4G je voudrais gagner encore
un petit peu en prix c'est peut-être là
où je vais aller sur le redmi note 13 et
que ensuite je vais venir switcher
directement ici sur le A15 5G qui est
quand même pas mal à 249 balles et là où
c'est marrant c'est qu'en fait ils
sortiront un peu plus tard dans l'année
hop là ils doivent être ici et bien les
A35 5G les A55 5G ce qui fait que pour
l'instant on a toujours les A34 5G les
A54 5G a des tarifs qui baissent est-ce
qu'il le rend extrêmement intéressant le
A34 5G il était à 349 il est à 319 €
écran de 6,6 pouces Super amolet 120 Hz
capteur principal de 48 stabilisation
petit qui est très très cool et puis
après au lieu de 449 à 419 € vous avez
les Galaxy A54 le Galaxy A54 c'est le
même écran 6,4 pouces un peu plus petit
mais bon ça va 120 Hz Super AMOLED
capteur principal de 50 mégapixel qui
est franchement super intéressant donc
si je veux regarder le Galaxy A54 5g et
que je viens le mettre en face d'un
Xiaomi redmi note 13 pro plus on est à
499 € je pense que pour l'instant ça
vaut le coup d'aller à 419 € sur le
Galaxy A54 même si c'est smartphone qui
a déjà 7 8 mois de vie au lieu d'aller
peut-être ce mois-ci sur le redmi note
13 pro à 399 € et bien ça peut valoir le
cûp d'aller sur le Galaxy A34 5G à 39 €
d'un point de vue financier c'est quand
même une belle affaire al il y en a don
je vous parle plus parce qu'il a
augmenté en tarif alors que pour autant
je l'adore en terme de design c'est
celui-là c'est le noing phone one il est
revenu à 469 € alors que le mois dernier
il était à 329 € donc bon il a beau me
plaire on r noing phone to un peu plus
lo par contre le vrai bon plan je vous
jure le vrai vrai vrai vrai bon plan là
pour moi tout de suite entre 200 et 500
balles c'est le pixel 7a qui était à 59
€ qui est tombé à 399 € il a perdu 100
balles et à 100 balles franchement ça
vaut vraiment le coup vous avez un super
smartphone avec toutes les nouvelles
fonctionnalités qu'ils envoi les pixel
drop entouré pour chercher les compagnie
bref vous avez plein de choses à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment un smartphone
que je vous recommande à ce tarif là
excellent photophone performant bel
écran belle expérience Android pur là à
peu moins de 400 balles vraiment vous en
AZ pour votre argent donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment intéressant unre
smartphone qui est cool mais qui a pas
trop bougeant tarif c'est le Honor 90
qui a un peu moins de 500 balles c'est
un très très bon smartphone avec plein
plein de très jolis techno mais c'est
vrai que le tarif à 500 balles il a pas
trop bougé on aurait envie qu'il est un
petit peu diminuer par rapport à la
concurrence mais non voilà c'est pas le
cas par contre à côté de ça vous avez un
très joli écran en terme de photo il
fait vraiment l'affaire capteur 200
mgapixel pour le coup marche bien il y a
plein de techno aussi pour venir prendre
soin de vos yeux Cami Honor ici
directement dans son smartphone il est
bien mais je trouve un peu cher
aujourd'hui et si je regarde par rapport
à ce que jeetrouve alors bien évidemment
chez Samsung 419 € mais surtout je vous
disais tout à l'heure par rapport au
pixel 7a à 399 € 399 € versus quasiment
500 balles bon il y a un truc après il y
a un autre smartphone qui est cool que
j'aime beaucoup aussi c'est le Motorola
Edge 40 néo 399 € ça va il continue à
vooir le coût j'aime beaucoup le design
je trouve super joli je vous l'avais
déjà présenté bien évidemment sur
youtube il est très très très très sympa
il est honnête il est correct et il est
au même prix aujourd'hui que le pixel 7a
alors si j' choisi entre les deux je
préférerai aller sur le pixel 7a deux
produits américains mais je dois
reconnaître que Google pousse tellement
souvent des nouvelles fonctionnalités
avec les pixel drop que ça vaut le coup
et puis il y en a bien évidemment un
autre que je vous ai présenté il y a pas
longtemps c'est le Honor Magic 6 Lite
qui est à 349,90 € 8 256 € ils ont
vraiment fait le focus sur la résistance
il a aussi une belle autonomie un très
joli écran qui est incurvé que j'aime
beaucoup la photo sur le capter
principal est correct franchement ça
roule et vraiment très très bien donc ça
c'est pareil c'est un smartphone que
j'aime bien qui est à
349,90 € donc après par rapport à votre
budget à vous de voir est-ce que vous
préférz aller à 349 € sur ce modèle là
est-ce que on peut rajouter 50 balles de
plus et on va sur le pixel 7a ce qui
peut aussi être une très jolie affaire
allez maintenant je vous emmène dans les
smartphones de gaming petite parenthèse
il y en a à tous les prix on va
commencer par poco qui a changé aussi
qui a renouvelé des produits avec deux
nouveaux produits qui sont arrivés vous
avez le X6 et le X6 pro alors ce qui
fera la différence bien évidemment c'est
le tarif le X6
299,90 € on est dans l'idée de
l'expérience de gaming avec un pros qui
est très correct le Snapdragon 7S 2 qui
est très bien un écran c'est de l'Amoled
120 Hz il faut le taux de
rafraîchissement pour le gaming c'est
obligatoire les photos je vous dis on
passe un peu on s'en fout un peu ce qui
est intéressant c'est la charge rapide
et la grosse autonomie ça c'est pour le
poco X6 un peu moins de 300 balles après
il y a le modèle Pro le modèle Pro on
est à 350 balles à peu près là on va
aller un peu plus loin performance on
est sur un mdiatch diman City 8300 ultra
on est sur un écran amolet toujours 120
Hz la photo on passe toujours de la
recharge rapide toujours la grosse
batterie bon qui est intéressant je
pense qu'il y a le le bon compromis
entre les deux ça peut être celui-à le
poco X6 je dis le tarif on voit pas trop
299,90 € pour moi ça vaut le coup c'est
vraiment vraiment intéressant après il y
a d'autres produits qui sont toujours
très cool dans la série F vous avez le
poco F5 le F6 est pas sorti
369,90 € ou alors le poco F5 pro 449,90
€ on en a déjà parlé alors moi ce que je
conseillerais si vous pouvez monter un
petit peu en budget il y a un produit
qui est très très très cool et qui est
sorti il y a pas longtemps c'est
celui-là don je vous ai parlé le mois
dernier c'est le Red Magic 9 pro
pourquoi parce que vous avez une très
jolie expérience de gaming vous partez
sur la version 12 256 vous êtes à 649
alors après si on veut monter en RAM on
va augmenter le prix mais déjà en 12 Go
de RAM réellement il y a de quoi faire
très jolie expérience de gaming le
smartphone est performant le smartphone
est puissant vous avez un Snapdragon 8
Gen 3 c'est aujourd'hui le pros le plus
puissant sur le marché très bon
refroidissement avec l'ICE 13.0 vous
avez un écran AMOLED bien évidemment une
grosse batterie de 6500 mahh et la
recharge rapide 80 W alors forcément
c'est plus cher 649 € mais en tout cas
le smartphone est super intéressant il y
a un autre produit qui est sorti il y a
pas longtemps c'est pour moi
l'expérience de gaming ultime sur
smartphone que j'adore réellement c'est
ce qu'on trouve chez Asus avec le rock
phone rock Phone 8 Pro il a le 8 il y a
le 8 Pro je suis un très gros amoureux
des rock Phone 8 le tarif est aussi
beaucoup plus élevé moi je vous ai
présenté le 8 Pro il y a pas longtemps
1199 € c'est un gros budget je suis
complètement d'accord avec ça vous avez
le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 vous avez de la
RAM en lpddr 5x vous avez du stockage en
ufs 4.0 c'est du 512 là on y va direct
on peut monter 1 ta vous avez vu et puis
surtout c'est un smartphone qui est
juste extra ordinaire en terme
d'expérience parce que vous allez avoir
les air trigger sur le dessus il sont en
fait des vraiment des petits boutons que
vous avez là toute une expérience
globale et complète qu'on retrouve ici
vous avez Armory crate toute
l'expérience logiciel on peut venir
mettre le curseur où on veut plutôt de
la performance plutôt de l'économie très
bonne dissipation de chaleur il sont dû
vraiment retravailler une fois de plus
sur la dissipation de chaleur je vous en
parle vraiment dans la vidéo jeter un
œil l'écran est très grand 6,78 pouces
c'est de la moled ça déconne pas la
batterie est très belle aussi alors elle
est un peu plus petite qu'avant parce
qu'il a fallu gagner en place mais pour
autant le smartphone est très très cool
et puis vous avez toute cette partie là
avec des mini LED que je trouve
extraordinaires alors le tarif est là
aussi bien évidemment
1199,90 € c'est un peu cher cher on va
descendre sur le rockfone 8 à 1099,99 €
mais je recommanderai réellement si vous
pouvez rajouter les 100 balles de plus
pour aller sur le 8 Pro profiter de la
meilleure expérience de gaming sur
smartphone et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
bien allez on passe sur les 500 à 900
balles Xiaomi qui est toujours dans la
course avec son Xiaomi 13t à
649,90 avec des optiques LICA donc si
vous aimez la photo voulez un truc très
performant et bien vous avez vraiment de
quoi faire ici bien évidemment alors
vous allez voir parce qu'il y a d'autres
tarifs qui sont-être un peu plus cool à
la concurrence Xiaomi a toujours été la
marque qui défoncé au niveau des tarifs
avec des très gross specs le smartphone
reste très cool tion mais si on regarde
649,90 € et qu'on va regarder ce que
nous propose aujourd'hui ici regardez
Samsung avec son Galaxy S23 fe qui est
là ils ont baissé les prix on est à 699
€ on est à 599 € aujourd'hui j'irai
là-dessus de vous à moi mais bon je
pense quand même que Xiaomi a fait un
beau travail sur son Xiaomi 13t donc ça
vaut quand même le coup de venir le
conseiller après vous avez le 13t pro
qui est plus cher alors ils ont décendu
le tarif on était quasiment 1000 balles
on est aujourd'hui à 849,90 € il est
très bien mais bon il est un peu cher
non moi ce que je recommande tout de
suite et qui m'intéresse dans cette
gamme de prix c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment le Galaxy S23 fe version 128 ça
va 599 € ils ont vraiment réduit les
tarifs économie de 100 balles par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant ça c'est
vraiment génial parce que c'est un
smartphone qui est très complet qui
reprend l'essence même de la gamme S de
Samsung et on en parle dans quelques
instants de la gamme S vous allez voir
qu'avec ce qui arriv avec les S24 ça
fait vraiment pas rigoler avec lia et on
peut retrouver lia aussi he là-dedans
donc ça c'est quand même très très très
cool au niveau de la photo il est très
efficace corninguia glace 5 à l'avant à
l'arrière au niveau de la photo c'est
très bien capteur principal de 50 qui
fait le taf l'ultra grand tank va bien
le télé bon on a pour son argent je vais
vous dire ils ont pas pu mettre le
maximum de spec ici mais il est quand
même génial vidéo photo il est très bon
l'écran est bien il est performant bref
je le recommande réellement et à ce
tarif là il est super cool autre
smartphone qui me plaît beaucoup aussi
c'est le zenphone 10 de Asus il était à
799 il est tombé à 699 c'est le même
tarif que le mois dernier il a pas bougé
ici mais la particularité qu'il a c'est
que c'est un tout petit format qui tient
vraiment bien en main on a un écran de
moins de 6 pouces ça c'est quand même
très très bien alors après une fois de
plus je remets en perspective par
rapport à ce que j'ai ici chez Samsung
599 € 699 je pense qu'aujourd'hui tout
de suite si on veut vraiment un écran
moins de 6 pouces on va sur le zenfone
10 si maintenant c'est le budget qui
vous appelle ce qui est souvent le cas
et bien on va sur le Galaxy S23 fe qui
pour l'instant il un tarif très canon
donc tardez pas trop je sais pas si le
tarif va rester une fois de plus je vous
mets tous les liens juste en bas dans la
description are smartphone qui moi me
plaît bien c'est le Motorola le hedge40
parce que j'aime bien le design il est
très sympa il est bien specké et il est
à
599,90 € qui le laisse plutôt bien
positionné je trouve ici donc ça c'est
très très cool je vous l'ai déjà
présenté une fois de plus aller jeter un
coup d'œil sur ma vidéo autre produit
qui est très bien attendez il est où
c'est chez Google le pixel 8 il était à
799 € il est tombé à 699 € alors bien
évidemment on est plutôt dans le haut du
panier on est au même tarif qu'un
zenphone 10 mais il est quand même
vachement bien avec toute l'IA qu'on
retrouve ici à l'intérieur c'est vrai
que une fois de plus 699 je me dis
est-ce que ça vaut pas le coup d'aller
aujourd'hui sur C espèce de Flag chip
killer que nous a mis Samsung ici avec
le Galaxy S23 fe à 599 € j'aurais
toujours tendance à pousser dessus et
puis un autre coup de cœur mais qui pour
le coup a réaugmenté en tarif c'est le
noing phone 2 qui était le mois dernier
à 629 € et là ils nous l'ont mis à 729 €
ils ont remonté les tarifs en fait tout
simplement noing ici ils ont fait des
offres qui étaient sympa le mois dernier
et puis là ben ça remonte quoi donc bon
si vous cherchez par contre attention ça
c'est vraiment un smartphone coup de
cœur si vous cherchez quelque chose de
très différentiant avec la glyf
interface au dos un smartphone qui va
être totalement totalement différent
sous Android avec un noingos 2.0 qui est
vraiment vraiment cool un smartphone
très atypique franchement il faut y
aller alors ça coûte un peu plus cher
que le mois dernier et ça me fait raller
ça vaait le coup de le prendre le mois
dernier mais si vous voulez un
smartphone très différent très
différenciant vraiment vous pouvez y
aller parce que il est juste
extraordinaire alors il y en a un autre
chez crossc c'est le stellar X5 c'est
plus le smartphone qu'on va vouloir
prendre si on veut faire de l'outdoor
sur un smartphone résistant quia aussi
bien dans l'univers professionnel dans
l'univers familial avec plein de techno
très très actuels à un peu moins de 900
balles on veut du très résistant c'est
du très très résistant mais joli et
garantie 5 ans enfin bref un smartphone
qui est très très cool qui peut convenir
à monsieur madame tout le monde mais je
pense plus aux personnes qui ont un
usage mixte entre le sport le pro le
perso qui veulent un seul et même
smartphone pour moi ici le produit qui
répond qui est d'une marque française
c'est le stellar X5 de crossc et puis un
gros dernier que j'ai adoré qui est
toujours intéressant c'est le Honor
Magic 5 Pro alors on arrive un peu sur
la fin de vie du Honor Magic 5 Pro parce
qu' il y a le Honor Magic 6 pro qui
devrait être annoncé très bientôt
probablement lors du MWC à Barcelone
c'est en tout cas comme ça qu'il faisait
les les autres années normalement il
sortaiit au mois de mai donc je pense
qu'on peut encore venir un peu le
recommandé le tarif a baissé il était à
plus de 1000 balles il était tombé à un
peu à 999 € là il est tombé à 899,90 €
il reste très performant avec plein de
belles techno il est extraordinaire en
photo et très très très très bien
aujourd'hui le tarif baisse 12 Go de RAM
512 Go de stockage pour moi c'est aussi
un smartphone que je peux encore venir
aujourd'hui recommander sans aucun
problème après il y a le Magic 6 pro qui
va bientôt arriver mais pour l'instant
il est pas là donc on peut encore venir
recommandé aujourd'hui le Honor Magic 5
Pro vous avez vu grand écran 680 enfin
bref ça déconne pas triple optique 50
mégapixel il est vraiment vraiment cool
le pros reste très efficace le
snardragon 8 gen 2 le temps de venir
coucher vous avez le temps très grosse
batterie de 5100 voilà pour moi il est
vraiment très très bien sans oublier
bien évidemment la grosse sortie de ce
mois-ci c'est le Galaxy
S24 qui est incroyable et le Galaxy S24
qui est vraiment cool pour plein plein
plein plein plein de raisons déjà en
tarif il est positionné à 599,90 € alors
là il vous le marque si vous avez une
reprise c'est 519 € alors n'oubliez pas
il est également disponible chez mon
partenaire BR teléecom une fois de plus
le lien est juste en bas dans la
description et là ce qui est cool c'est
qu'il y a tout le focus qui est fait sur
l'intelligence artificielle que j'ai
testé et que je trouve vraiment
intéressant ça fonctionne vraiment bien
que ce soit pour la recherche entouré
pour chercher la traduction instantané
et quand même vraiment vraiment bien
l'assistant de retranscription qui
fonctionne bien également l'assistant en
photo aussi j'adore vraiment vraiment
plein plein de belles choses et c'est un
smartphone qui est super bien super
élégant des couleurs exclusives sur
Samsung.com une fois de plus le lien est
juste en bas dans la description allez
jeter un coup d'œil à ma vidéo de
présentation et il y a celle du S24
ultra où je vous montre les
fonctionnalités que vous retrouverez
également ici dans le Galaxy S24 et qui
est vraiment un super bon plan avant de
passer au smartphone à plus de 900 € je
voudrais qu'on fasse une petite
parenthèse pour les smartphones pour
seniors alors pour l'instant une
référence à venir vous présenter c'est
binom qui fait ça c'est une marque
française je vous l'avais présenté la
semaine dernière et surtout sont des
gens qui sont vraiment en France donc
qui vont s'adresser à un public de
senior ça vous l'avez compris et moi je
vous présente celui-là c'est le binome
SX1 229 € c'est vraiment intéressant C
cette idée du smartphone pour senior
parce que je sais pas si vous vos
grands-parents ou vos parents sont
peut-être âgés et ils veulent avoir un
moyen de communiquer et le smartphone
peut être intéressant pour eux alors
soit ils sont encore très amoureux de
téléphone un peu classique et ça leur
conviendra soit le smartphone peut être
fait pour eux pas la même expérience que
nous avec plein d'applications de tous
les côtés ça peut être un peu complexe
par contre ici voyez il vous mettre des
grosses icônes téléphone appareil photo
photo message c'est simple c'est
efficace les valeurs de la marque c'est
bien évidemment et bien d'avoir un SAV
où on va s'occuper de vous ils vont être
là pour pour pour vous aider la marque
est située en France et ça c'est quand
même vachement bien alors là on se parle
de 4g bien évidemment smartphone
intéressant on peut avoir également la
téléassistance 229 € ça vaut le coup
allez on passe tout de suite au
smartphone à plus de 900 € à commencer
par le pixel 8 Pro qui est vraiment
vraiment cool qui avait une nouvelle
fonctionnalité pas qu'une mais entre
autres une principale entourée pour
chercher que je vous ai présenté sur le
Samsung Galaxy S23 S24 pardon ultra
alleet un C G vidéo qui arrive donc bien
évidemment ici le tarif a baissé il
était à 1 1099 € et tombe à 949 € c'est
un gros budget certes mais c'est un
super smartphone photo performance écran
Android pur il est vraiment
extraordinaire pour moi ça vaut vraiment
le coup c'est un smartphone que je dois
vraiment venir recommander aujourd'hui
je vous parlais tout à l'heure du Galaxy
S24 il y a le Galaxy S24 plus qui va
être forcément un peu plus cher que le
Galaxy S24 on va trouver les mêmes
fonctionnalités mais il sera plus grand
on s'en doutera ici on est à partir de
1169 € alors il y a du bonus de reprise
bien évidemment plutôt intéressant pour
la version 12 256 des couleurs
exclusives bien évidemment au site
samsung.com si vous voulez un joli
orange vert ou bleu vous pouvez les
trouver uniquement sur Samsung.com une
fois de plus je vous renvoie au lien en
bas dans la description et c'est une
fois de plus un très très très très très
joli smartphone et puis bien évidemment
le gros smartphone coup de cœur pour moi
en ce début d'année c'est celui-là c'est
le Galaxy S24 ultra qui est incroyable
avec son SPN bien évidemment et puis
toute l'intelligence artificielle qu'on
vient retrouver à l'intérieur je vous
renvoie bien évidemment ma vidéo Youtube
pour tout savoir sur ce smartphone qui
est juste absolument incro incroyable et
je pèse mes mots le tarif aussi est un
peu coquin on va pas se mentir mais on
est dans l'ultra haut de gamme et c'est
comme ça
1469 € pour la version 12 256 mais le
smartphone est vraiment vraiment cool
avant qu'on se parle des iPhones dans
quelques instants je voudrais qu'on se
parle des smartphones pliants et ben oui
forcément il y en a énormément on va
commencer par Motorola avec ses razers
alors si vous avez suivi vous avez vu
que les derè sont sorti les nouveaux
Razer 40 et 40 ultra j'aime beaucoup ces
smartphones je trouve très cool alors le
Razer 40 il est plutôt cool on va le
retrouver à un tarif de
699,90 € assez maîtriser ils ont enlever
200 balles ici bon ok why not il y a le
40 ultra que j'aime beaucoup parce qu'en
fait vous allez avoir l'écran extérieur
qui englobe la partie photo et ça c'est
un truc qui me plaît bien aussi et
j'aime bien ce côté immersif qu'on ne
retrouve pas sur le Samsung Galaxy Z
flip 5 qui est moins immersif voyez là
ce qu'on a là ça me plaît bien c'est
quand même très très cool ils sont venus
diminuer le tarif on était à 1199 € on
tombe à 999 € mais c'est vrai qu'en face
aujourd'hui chez Samsung vous allez vous
retrouver avec un Galaxy zflip 5 qui est
voyons clair au même tarif et je
préférerai à ce moment-là aller sur le
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 5 donc c'est
peut-être le smartphone dans ce qu'on
appellerera aujourd'hui le format flip
que je viendrai recommander et qui est
vraiment cool alors après il y en a un
autre qui est aussi très bien c'est le
Galaxy zfold 5 de Samsung qui est à 1899
€ et qui est tombaé à 1649 € et c'était
sans compter sur la concurrence très
énervée de Honor qui a sorti son Honor
Magic V2 alors le tarif c'est
1999,90 € mais si vous regardez bien en
fait on va descendre là et voyez que
vous avez un coupon de 600 balles donc
ça vous le descend à
1399,90 € et si vous regardez ils vous
offre en plus une enceinte Marshall
standanb 3 qui coûte 399 € donc ce qui
fait qu'en fait une fois que vous avez
enlevé le coupon et une fois que vous
avez votre Enceinte Marchall offert ça
vous le ramène peu au prou à 1000 balles
vous le dépensez bien évidemment
l'argent vous récupérez le coupon on
vous offre une enceinte vous dépensez de
l'argent oui mais vous avez le
smartphone pliant le plus fin au monde
allez voir ma vidéo sur Youtube vous
allez voir il est vraiment vraiment cool
c'est un beau budget mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si je viens le comparer
par rapport à ce que nous propose
Samsung juste par rapport au tarif et
par rapport à la finesse et bien je
tendance aujourd'hui à envoyer sur le
Honor Magic V2 qui est soyons clair
vraiment bien allez on fait un tour du
côté des iPhones c'est toujours une
question d'argent mais si on pouvait
tous se payer un iPhone 15 pro ou un 15
pro max je pense qu'on le ferait donc
pour moi aujourd'hui les iPhone 13 il
continue à être intéressant pour moi on
peut y aller si on les trouve en neuf ou
en reconditionné voyez l'iPhone 13 à
partir de 749 € ça vaut le coup et je
peux y aller il est vraiment vraiment
bien 128 ça va ça reste cohérent on peut
aller en 256 pour être un peu plus
tranquille ça va mais 128 c'est honnête
donc l'iPhone 13 pour moi vous pouvez
encore y aller aujourd'hui l'iPhone 12
également aussi si vous le retrouvez en
reconditionné je pense que c'est un truc
qui est vraiment intéressant je vous
emmène chez Smart c'est pas sponsoriséve
Smart he mais je vais quand même vous
montrer chez eux parce que c'est un truc
qui peut vraiment valoir le coup alors
64 Go c'est un peu petit ça m'embête
toujours je préférerais avoir un truc un
peu plus gros en 128 voyez là j'en ai un
alors faut voir l'état mais je suis à un
peu moins de 400 balles donc moi je peux
aller sur un iPhone 12 128 à un peu
moins de 400 balles et ça me pose aucun
problème c'est vraiment très très bien
l'iPhone 13 reste aussi vraiment bien et
si on peut se le permettre bien
évidemment on va bienenir monter au
niveau de l'iPhone 14 parce que même
s'il y a des amélioration d'une
génération à l'autre avec une puce qui
va être meilleure sur la version Pro si
vous prenez la version Pro de l'iPhone
14 deannée dernière et si vous prenez
l'iPhone 15 et 15 plus de cette année
vous avez la même puce si vous trouvez
un iPhone il les ontlevés chez Apple les
iPhone 15 pro mais si vous trouvez un
iPhone 15 pro un tarif vraiment
intéressant dans le commerce ça vaut le
coup sinon pou aller sur un iPhone 14 ou
un iPhone 14 plus vous ne rougirez pas
certes on est à 869 € mais vous ne
rougirez pas c'est un très très bon
smartphone et puis après vous PvE aller
sur les iPhone 15 bien évidemment sans
aucun problème 969 €. ensuite on a les
versions Pro on ira plus loin avec le
téléobjectif c'est toujours une question
de budget je dirais que celui
aujourd'hui qui est un peu moins la page
mais qu'on peut toujours acheter si on
veut vra iOS qu'on s'en fout un peu du
design et bien c'est l'iPhone se qui
commence vraiment à vieillir le design
al il est totalement dépassé mais il
commence un peu quand même à vieillir
avec ce qu'il a dans le ventre la
version 64 pour moi je la prends pas
parce que j'ai pas assez de stockage
mais la version 128 599 € si vous voulez
iOS en ne9uf chez Apple pourquoi pas
voilà pour cette sélection pour le mois
de février 2024 dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez bien évidemment juste en bas dans
les commentaires quel smartphone vous
fait de l'œil et puis surtout dites-moi
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que je
modifie que je fasse évoluer que je
change un peu la façon de faire cette
vidéo est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que
au lieu de vous donner plein de
références et les prix que je vous dis
c'est celui qu'il faut acheter celui-là
celui-là j'en parle pas diteslemoi bien
évidemment dans les commentaires et puis
puisquon se parle de smartphone on se
parle d'écran je vous ai fait une vidéo
les SEP erreurs qui flinguent nos yeux
sur les écrans allez la voir ça n permet
de voir les petites erreurs qu'on fait
tous et de venir les corriger allez voir
c'est juste
ici